kamla harris has accepted the democratic
party's nomination
for the post of vice president of the
united states
it is the first time a woman of black
and indian american heritage
has been nominated for such a position
by any major u.s
political party besides the u.s her
candidature is also generating
excitement
in the country of her mother's birth
india
a nation where kamala still has family
ties
but the question really is if and how
that will impact relations between the
us and india
panes of kamala harris not in the united
states
but in india the possibility of an
indian american becoming the next u.s
vice president
is stoking national pride especially in
her grandparents native chennai
in the south of the country it gives me
immense pride as a woman to learn that a
woman with roots in this city is all set
for the u.s vice presidential election
if you see it's the second generation
right
and if you see how wonderfully she has
brought up the two girls
they are so very well educated and yet
rooted
they have not forgotten where they
belong
kamala harris invoked her indian
heritage while accepting her nomination
for the u.s vice presidency
and there's another woman whose name
isn't known
whose story isn't shared another woman
whose shoulders i stand on and that's my
mother
shamala gopalan harris
she came here from india at age 19
to pursue her dream of curing cancer
many indians wonder what a winning biden
harris ticket in november would mean for
relations with the united states
she should win the election and she
should also be in favor of
india what she does to the us and
how the american diplomacy with india
will be or will exist after she became
the vice president that's all matters
a sentiment many in india will see as
the true test of kamala harris's indian
heritage
let's get more on this druva joshanker
is director of the u.s initiative of the
indian think tank
the observer research foundation and he
joins me now from
washington dc driver great to have you
on the program
just straight off the bat would it make
any difference to u.s
india ties if kamala harris were to be
elected vice president
of the united states
i mean i think the short answer is
actually no uh that she's running for
vice president of the united states not
of india
um she will be you know i think as a us
leader and she's shown this as a senator
and in other positions during her
political career
that that you know she will be it's
natural that she'll be looking out
uh for the best interests of uh the
united states in its uh foreign
relations
um and uh so so i mean i think that
that's really
at the the key uh in some ways her story
you know i mean it's quite it's quite
natural that people uh
in india will see uh in her story a sort
of a story of inspiration and and be
proud of
of what she and her family have achieved
in um
but ultimately it will have as much of
an impact on u.s india relations as
barack obama's presidency had for
u.s kenya relations which is not very
much uh
that's an interesting analogy then why
does kamala harris keep bringing up her
indian heritage for example in her
speeches
well it is a remarkable story her mother
coming uh
as a very young student to the united
states by herself
and meeting you know kamala harris's
father
uh raising two children as a single
mother being becoming you know getting a
phd
it is quite a remarkable life story uh
so it's it's interesting you know it is
it makes sense for her to to to hearken
up uh back up
upon it um but the other thing is i
think there is definitely an attempt to
appeal to
indian american voters and people you
know uh
for women uh people who you know will
find inspiration in kamla harris's
heritage and background so i think that
a big reason why even in her speech last
night where she
uh you know she used the tamil word uh
the the indian language word for uh for
her aunts
uh something like that will resonate
very positively with a lot of indian
american voters speaking of the indian
american vote
uh dhruva is it important only to get
candidates elected or does it
also somehow impact relations between
india and the u.s
um there is some relation uh of course i
mean for a lot of indian-american voters
um the relation good relations between
the united states and india
does matter it is one of the issues uh
on their policy agenda that they would
like to see
um to see materialized and and so so i
in that sense we did see for example on
saturday on august 15th which is india's
independence day both
joe biden and kamala harris making a
statement about
uh two to the indian american community
on india's independence day um so
there is that that connection but
ultimately i think this is this is
really about
a minority community in the in the
united states um and they have a set of
uh issues one of only one of which is
relations with
with india that resonate in that matter
quite a lot for them i'd like to talk to
you about the indian government surely
there would be a preference potentially
in the current indian government
dealing either with a biden white house
or a trump white house
which do you think they prefer and why
uh you know i don't think there's a
strong preference either way i think
each
uh candidacy and each platform uh offers
certain
advantages uh from an indian point of
view um
and certain disadvantages as well so for
example with uh you know
trump has taken uh competition with
china quite seriously and sometimes to
the benefit of the u.s india's strategic
relationship uh
in some ways india has been a major
beneficiary of trump's free and open
indo-pacific policies
uh at the same time i think that there
are deep and abiding concerns about
trump's
approach to trade his approach to
immigration uh and
those two things in particular uh and uh
i expect if
should he be re-elected that he would
take a much stronger position especially
on on immigration which will have
uh some negative impact for india uh on
the other hand you know the
administration i think will uh be much
you know
much more open to partnering with india
on issues like trade and climate change
particularly so the
the latter being something that has been
off the agenda um
and uh you know we'll offer some relief
from an indian point of view on
immigration
but there are concerns about how
seriously they will take the
geopolitical
approach to to china and and to pakistan
to to issues that india has
serious concerns about so so i think
each candidacy offers certain
upsides and downsides from an indian
perspective we leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
joining us druva jaishankar speaking to
us from washington dc